so one of the things that I learned by
working with all these investors was
that there are some common steps that we
all need to take whether you got a
thousand dollars a hundred thousand
dollars a million dollars ten million
dollars the the idea that most people
make the biggest mistake first most
people make is they think they need a
lot of money to make a lot of money and
the truth of the matter is the greatest
investor started with very little what
they really learned to do is to use the
power of what basically when I asked
Warren Buffett I said what's been your
secret to wealth he said three things he
said number one was being born in
America number two his good genes I
lived a long time and number three was
compound interest he said that's it and
most people don't understand you can tap
that power if you look at people that
make a lot of money and you think that's
what's gonna make him rich you can go
look like it like Kim Basinger who there
won the Academy Award and you know she
was at the highest paid actress of her
day made ten million dollars a picture
and turned around about a twenty million
dollar town and went bankrupt you know
mike tyson mike tyson made a half a
billion dollars and went bankrupt curt
schilling of the boston redsox
you know major leaguer you know MVP
amazing guy made 100 million dollars
went bankrupt so it's not what you earn
it's taking a small amount of money and
consistently investing at this what
really matters there's a gentleman named
Theodore Johnson who was a UPS driver he
never made more than $14,000 in his
lifetime and in his old ages worth 70
million dollars how did he do it he
pretended there was a 20% tax on his
income he said I don't have any money to
save but if there is a tax I'd have to
pay it
he automated taking 20 percent his money
putting it straight in investment
account made him worth seventy million
dollars that's all he did never made
more than 14 grand so you don't want to
make that first mistake you want to
become an owner not a consumer you don't
want us to have an iPhone you want to
own Apple right you want more
importantly one owned across the market
as a whole and become an owner of
American business but if you decide
you're gonna do that bottom eight the
second step I teach is you've got to
become an Insider you've got to know the
rules of the game before you get in the
game because the system is not set up
for the individual investor to win the
system it's not evil it's set up by
corporations and corporations number-one
priority is to maximize profits for the
shareholders it's not to maximize
profits for the investor
and that's the conflict that we see
happening over and over again so as a
result there's a lot of market marketed
myths and one of those myths is that if
you go to somebody they're gonna beat
the market you talk to Warren Buffett
he'll tell you it's not gonna happen
ray value it's not gonna happen David
Swensen is the head of Yale's funds took
them from 1 billion to 24 billion in two
decades it says it's not gonna happen
nobody meets the market long term like I
just told you 96% of mutual funds don't
do it over a 10-year period of time so
and then the cost of them though is the
real challenge not only do they not beat
the market you get sub performance and
this is your future but also people say
things like it's only 1% most people
have asked them what are you paying fees
they don't know or they say 1% 1% is
called the expense ratio that's like a
top line on the sticker price of
something but if you read the 50 page
perspectives which most people will
never do you'll find there are 17 other
costs they may not call them fees but
their costs that come off the top Forbes
found that the average mutual fund has
three point one two percent in costs now
1% 3% goes so what what's 3 percent well
if you're getting a 6% return you're
knitting
less than 3% you gotta pay taxes on that
one and a half percent it's gonna take
you 60 years to be able to double your
money it's never gonna get anywhere but
more importantly just like your
investments compound so two costs so for
example if you start out with three
people they all start out at 30 years
old 35 years old let's say and they had
$100,000 each and they start growing it
at 7% a year for 30 years till they're
65 years old what's the impact of 1 2 or
3%
well the highlight is at 1% your
$100,000 would now be worth five hundred
seventy four thousand if you never added
another dime you're three percent of
these means you'd have four hundred
twenty four thousand dollars that's
seventy seven percent less money a
quarter of a million dollars less money
so people don't understand that it's
like if you want to win a race and it's
a horse race do you want a hundred pound
jockey or three of the jockey one
hundred pound jockey is one percent
thieves the 300-pound jockey is 3
percent fees and I'm here to tell you
it's not gonna work I'll give you one
more distinction if someone came to you
and said I'd like you to make an
investment it here's how we're gonna do
it you put up all the money you take
all the risk I put up no money I take no
risk and at the end if you lose I make
money and if you win I make money and if
you win over the lifetime of your
investments 30 or 40 years I'll end up
with about 60% of your total returns
would you do it you'd say Oh that's
absurd it never do in a million years
that's most mutual funds that's the
average mutual fund because every 1% is
20% of your total compounded interest of
growth over the lifetime of 30 or 40
years of investing Jack bull doesn't
want to taught me that's mind-boggling
so the rule the the lie is we're gonna
beat the market the second lie is if
we're gonna it's only 1% the third lie
is the fees we show or the returns we
show you were real
I will go through this now but mutual
funds do not report the actual returns
you get Jack Bogle pointed this out to
me Jack Bogle is head of Vanguard been
in the business 63 years built the
largest mutual fund in the world and he
did it by stripping out all the fees
I'll give you an example on this he's
been arguing like crazy people should
know what their real returns on not
their average return not the return that
the fund got for the year but you got if
you remember some people are old enough
to remember Peter Lynch a gentleman with
fidelity he created the Magellan fund
from 1977 to 1990 he averaged a 29%
return during that time unbelievable
when Magellan did their studies the
average investor made zero they lost
money how is that possible fees and also
going in now the market because people
couldn't take it they didn't know what
they're doing it in that stage so one of
the things that we're in in the mutual
fund area and in the area of investing
is it's one of the few areas on earth
where people get so confused they don't
know what it means they hear a number
it's too complex and I give it over so
what I like to do is cut through that
cut through all the fine print show you
what it really means I give you an
example this really really simple if if
you really want to be financially free
every value has to be captured and it
needs to grow for you every dollars not
growing for you is growing for somebody
else you don't want to be creating the
retirement for your broker your
retirement for yourself so you have to
be aware of this the last thing I'll
tell you one more myth is after first
delivering subpar results compared to
the market
after putting yourself in a position
where you know you're paying high fees
after telling you returns that really
aren't yours the person will likely
looking in the face and say I'm looking
out for your best interest and they may
sincerely think they are people that
work in the financial industry have high
integrity there's some people in every
industry that aren't great but the
problem is they're part of a captive
system if I'm a butcher and you come to
ask me what should I have for dinner I'm
gonna sell you meat one form of meat or
another it's something that I have
that's my job to do that if you went to
a dietitian they might say to you hey
wait a second buddy all that red meat
you're gonna you're gonna die of a heart
attack have some salad let's have some
fish tonight if you go to your broker
you're going to a butcher they're a good
person they believe it they might even
put their own money there but they don't
know how to look at the overall of what
you need they're paid to sell if you go
to the dietician which I'll give your
audience a new word for some of your new
F words called fiduciary and that word
is a fiduciary is a person that legally
is required to look out for your best
interest if they tell you to by
Microsoft this morning and they buy the
stock this afternoon and they get it
cheaper than you they have to give you
the cheaper stock that's how strong the
rules are they are only paid to
recommend what's best for you they make
no commissions a fiduciary somebody
who's a skilled fiduciary is incredibly
valuable to your life and by the way
they don't have to cost you a lot of
money they cost very little or you can
give a small percentage but you're not
paying all the commissions you're just
paying one time for them to give you the
advice and ongoing they guide you so
these are a couple of the areas that
people have to use to become an Insider
I say to people you want to become the
chess player not the chess piece and
this book really shows you how
you